nothing is absolute certainly not in
Hollywood and while it may be true that
remakes are almost always worse than the
originals there are some notable
exceptions in fact some remakes are just
as good as the original they're even
better Frank Sinatra Dean Martin Sammy
Davis jr. and the rest of the Rat Pack
were riding high in the early 1960s so
they decided to make a movie
the result is Ocean's eleven a film
which feels like a big-budget vanity
project because well it is Frank Sinatra
stars is Danny ocean who assembles his
82nd airborne buddies to rob five Las
Vegas casinos on New Year's Day in 2001
Steven Soderbergh and a crew of
Hollywood's cruelest remade Ocean's
eleven into the film the original wanted
to be George Clooney assumes command is
Danny ocean with Matt Damon Brad Pitt's
and Julia Roberts joining the crew the
resulting film showcases a high story
that moves us confidently as its
star-studded cast today's lesson how to
draw out the bluff that much money this
early in the game I'm saying he's
holding nothing better than a pair of
face cards Disney was in a dark place in
1977 the studio's golden and silver ages
of the 1930s through the late 1960s were
over and Disney was clearly adrift on
the animation front as well as in its
live-action offerings case in point
1977 Pete's dragon while the story of an
orphan boy named Pete's and his magical
dragon named Eliot's effectively mixes
live action and hand-drawn animation
that's about all it does well however
studio execs saw something in the story
and brought it back almost 40 years
later in 2016 s pete's dragon the remake
fared a bit better critically thanks to
incredible special effects and a stellar
live action cast rounded out by Robert
Redford John Wayne made a career out of
playing John Wayne and in doing so
became one of America's most iconic
movie stars ever but out of all of
Wayne's movies only one won him an Oscar
1969 s True Grit based on Charles Portis
1968 novel True Grit tells the story of
a young girl named Mattie Ross who hires
the drunken eyepatch wearing u.s.
marshal Rooster Cogburn to hunt down the
man that killed her father
Walt Wayne's megawatt movie star bravado
made up for it his true grit was missing
poor toises deft prose the Coen brothers
made up
that 50 years later returning to port
is's novel to create a more faithful
adaptation Jeff Bridges down the
eyepatch this time breathing new life
into the whiskey breath rooster and
securing an Oscar nomination along the
way
unlike Wayne bridges didn't win an Oscar
for True Grit still the 1969 original
was more of a star vehicle resting on
Wayne's broad shoulders while the 2010
remake was top-to-bottom the better film
they tell me your man with true grit the
thing from another world is one of the
best 1950s sci-fi films and although it
boasts no shortage of fine qualities one
main reason for its success is the
director not the credited director
Charles naívi but the real director
Howard Hawks who presented the film but
didn't take a directing credit credit or
no credit make no mistake this is a
Howard Hawks movie with crackling
dialogue competent competent heroes on a
hawkish worldview that said while
audiences 1951 were probably scared
stiff viewers today wouldn't lose any
sleep over the spell that's not the case
with John Carpenter's the thing which
came out in 1982 the first of carpenters
apocalypse trilogy the things truly
terrifying sfx and storytelling
supersedes the original in the most
important way it's much much scarier
thanks in no small part to a
delightfully ambiguous ending what do we
do we just
wait here for a little while
[Music]
see what happens Al Pacino and Robert De
Niro's first onscreen faceoff and
Michael Mann's heat was a cinematic
milestone the two co-starred in the
Godfather Part two without sharing any
screen time so by the time he'd arrived
in 1995 film fans were ecstatic to
finally see them tradelines
he proved to be a bit of a tease in this
respect but the film's quality extends
beyond its star power while this was the
first time Pacino and De Niro met on
screen it wasn't the first time this
story was adapted after making waves
with TVs Miami Vice man wanted to make
another cop drama on the golden coast
his script eventually became a 1989 TV
movie called la take down working with a
TV sized budget and lacking the
star-studded cast of its successor
takedown has gone on to become a
footnote in man's career especially
compared to heat it is one of Stephen
King's most popular novels so it was
inevitable that had become a movie at
some point still this gruesome story
about a supernatural killer spanning
decades doesn't exactly scream TV
mini-series that was exactly what
happened in 1990 however while the
miniseries isn't exactly bad with Tim
Curry clearly relishing his role as
penny wise this two-part adaptation just
lacks the visceral all-consuming terror
the story demands Kings it is an epic
story that demands an R rating and all
the bells and whistles that come with
big-budget blockbuster filmmaking in
2017 that's exactly what fans gots in
the form of the first chapter of a
two-part film adaptation liked by
critics and loved by moviegoers released
two years later it chapter two lacked
the freshness and urgency of its
predecessor still while the miniseries
has its fans the 2017 in 2019 movies are
the definitive screen versions of Kings
classics so far released in 1991 lotto
towel is a comedy about a humdrum civil
servant who is actually a crack secret
agent though his family has no idea does
this sound like the plot of James
Cameron's true lies one of the biggest
hits of 1994 and the first movie to have
a hundred million dollar budget
it should True Lies is actually a remake
of lotto towel only now with Arnold
Schwarzenegger in the role of the nerd
spy and Jamie Lee Curtis as is unaware
white bottle towel is perfectly fine for
what it is but Cameron had a very
different vision for the story he took
the already absurd plots
Lotso Thailand dialed it up to 11
transforming the silly French flick into
a mega budgeted action-packed
blockbuster with bridges getting blown
up horses racing up skyscrapers and
Arnie blasting a bad guy from the rocket
of a Harrier jet it's a good thing he
did since True Lies is a much better
movie for it critics dug it while
audiences showed up in droves to make
the film a massive success domestically
and around the world when you think
great comedic duo Steve Martin and
Michael Caine probably don't spring
immediately to mine yet the chemistry
between the Texas born California raised
superstar stand-up comedian and the
cocky Brad two-time Academy
award-winning English thespian is
absolutely undeniable and dirty rotten
scoundrels however there was another
pairing of an American and a Brit in the
same story that didn't have quite the
same chemistry Marlon Brando and David
Niven and bedtime story released in 1964
bedtime story is about a small change
scammer played by Brando and a
high-class cultured con artist played by
Niven who compete for innocent woman's
cash in the Mediterranean it was a great
set up but the film failed to impress
and fell into movie oblivion however
sensing the promise of the premise
martin kane and director frank oz remade
it 24 years later in 1988 as dirty
rotten scoundrels it worked out pretty
well as the film went on to be well
liked by critics and regular moviegoers
alike it even inspired a 2005 Broadway
musical hoping that Lightning would
strike twice the story was remade again
31 years later in 2019 with Anne
Hathaway and rebel Wilson as the hustle
the critics weren't nearly as kind of
the three versions of the story were
convinced Martin and Kane made the best
con artists inspired by advancing
technology Cold War paranoia and fears
of nuclear war the 1950s was a golden
age for sci-fi still one film that truly
stood out in that era was 1958 the fly
starring genre staple Vincent Price in a
supporting role the fly is about a
scientist experimenting with a
teleportation device who accidentally
ends up splicing his own atoms with
those of a housefly flash-forward 28
years later to 1986 David Cronenberg's
the fly takes the unsettling source
material into much darker more
disturbing directions in the hands of
pronin Berg the fly becomes arguably the
best body horror film
all time it's a horror film that stays
with you not only because it's scary but
because it's sad
while the fly is one of the best sci-fi
horror films of the 1950's Cronenberg
Supply is one of the best films period
will be the ultimate family three joined
together one body more human and I
applause in 1960 screenwriter charles
beat Griffith and Bane low-budget
b-movie author Roger Corman created a
killer plant named Audrey in the Little
Shop of Horrors the film is considered a
cult classic today but Audrey's roots in
American pop culture were eventually to
grow even deeper before making Disney
billions as the lyricist and composer
for the Little Mermaid and Beauty and
the Beast Howard Ashman and Alan Menken
produced the stage musical version of
Corman's cult classic in 1982 this
musical inspired the 1986 film version
starring Rick Moranis as Audrey's Keeper
with Steve Martin stealing scenes as a
demented dentist the 1986 version
underperformed at the box office but
it's since earned a sizable cult
following of its own has there ever been
an actor who's able to choose scenery
like Al Pacino maybe 50 years before Al
Pacino told audiences to say hello to
his little friend as Tony Montana Paul
Mooney racked up an equally impressive
body count as tony camonte a Howard
Hawks is 1932 Scarface had a story that
should be familiar to fans of Brian De
Palma's 1983 remake a low-ranking
homicidal hood works his way up the
gangster corporate ladder sadistically
wiping out his foes while maintaining a
soft spot for his little sister
camote is Italian not Cuban and instead
of peddling cocaine its booze but
otherwise the stories are the same Fox's
Scarface is a classic so what makes the
1983 remake better its exploration of
excess continues to inspire pop culture
to this day particularly hip hop culture
bubble films are strong Pacino state
continues to resonate like few gangster
films ever had before or since
so say good night to the bad guy when
you think of the Wizard of Oz you
probably think of Judy Garland's bright
red sparkling shoes or maybe the
lustrous glittering gold of the yellow
brick road you probably think of color
Technicolor Beast
however while The Wizard of Oz was one
of the first films to be shot in color
it wasn't the first time l frank Baum's
story hit the silver screen 14 years
before the Oz we all know and love was
released there was another version the
original 1925 version interpreted the
story as a heavy-handed slapstick silent
comedy unfortunately it isn't even funny
which is saying something considering it
featured Oliver Hardy as the Tin Man
thankfully a movie studio still saw
something in the story and remade it
1939 Hollywood just can't seem to get
enough of james fenimore cooper's last
of the Mohicans
written in 1826 it's been filmed eleven
times one of the earliest adaptations
was the 1920 silent film version
followed by a 1936 version starring
Randolph Scott's as Hawkeye and Bruce
Cabot Desmond WA besides the unpleasant
whitewashing of the Native American
antagonist the 1936 version is otherwise
an acceptable if not particularly
memorable 1930s Hollywood adventure
picture nearly six decades later
director Michael Mann would leave the
sunny pastel-colored world of Miami Vice
and take on this 18th century story
casting Daniel day-lewis as Hawkeye and
Native American actors to play Native
American characters funnily enough man
is said to have bass the script for his
film less on the novel and more on the
1936 version Philip done that adaptation
screenwriter even received a credit
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]